[Music]
hey friends welcome to another episode
of machine learning experts i'm your
host brittany muller
and today's expert is none other than
sasha luccione
sasha is a research scientist here at
hugging face where she works on projects
that are at the intersection of
environmental impact and ai
you'll hear sasha talk about how she's
measured the carbon footprint of an
email
how she helped a local suit kitchen
leverage the power of machine learning
and just how
meaning and creativity fuel her work
if you're interested in learning how
machine learning experts like sasha can
help you accelerate your machine machine
learning roadmap please visit hf dot co
support to learn more
uh super excited to share this episode
with all of you sasha is so passionate
and so insightful on these topics that i
know you'll get a lot out of it so
here is my conversation with sacha
luccione
thank you so much for joining us today
we are so excited to have you on i'm
really excited to be here
so diving right in curious if you could
speak a little bit to your background i
know you have a really interesting
journey that brought you to hugging
phase
yeah actually i mean if we go all the
way all the way back i actually uh
started um
studying in linguistics i wasn't super
into languages and i'm like actually
both my parents are mathematicians so i
was like i don't want to do math i want
to do language um and then i started
like drifting i started doing nlp uh
some natural language processing um like
during my undergrad like i got super
super into it and then i like slowly but
surely started like and my um my last my
phd was in computer science but like
still with the linguistic um angle i
guess so i was always kind of like i
started out really um in the humanities
and then and then got into computer
science and then after my phd i spent a
couple of years working in applied um ai
research
so um like my last job was in finance um
and then one day i decided that i wanted
to
do kind of good and socially positive uh
ai research so i quit my job i decided
that you know no amount of money was
worth uh
working on just you know
kind of
kind of ai for ai's sake i wanted to do
more and so i spent a couple of years
working uh with yash yashwa benjio at
mila working on ai for good project say
climate change projects and then i was
looking for like my next uh my next role
and i wanted to be in a place that i you
know i i trusted was was doing the right
things and going the right direction so
hugging face when i when i met tom and i
met clem i i knew that it was a place
for me and that it would be exactly what
i was what i was looking for i love that
and i think you strike such an accord
with you know you wanted to do something
that felt meaningful
and i feel like that's something we
don't talk about enough and it is a
driving force you know kind of baked
into
our dna i feel like
yeah when i hear people like
you know sunday evening being like
monday's tomorrow i'm like monday
tomorrow is monday that's great
and it's not that i'm a workaholic like
i i definitely do other stuff like have
a family and everything but i'm like
literally excited to go to work and to
like do really cool stuff so so i think
that's important i know people can live
without it but i can't
so important what are you most excited
that you're working on now
i think the the big science project is
definitely like super uh inspiring um
for the last couple of years i've been
seeing these large language models and
they i was always like but but like how
do they work and where's their code and
where's their data and like what was
going on in there and like how are they
developed and who was involved and it
was all such kind of like a black box
thing and i'm so happy that we're
finally like making it a glass box and
there's so many people involved and so
many like really interesting
perspectives and so i'm sharing them the
carbon footprint working group so we're
working on you know even different
aspects of environmental impacts and
above and beyond just like counting the
co2 emissions but like other things like
you know the manufacturing costs and
even at some point we're like well what
does it what how much co2 does an email
generate things like that so so we're
definitely thinking of um different
perspectives and and also about the data
uh i'm involved in a lot of the data
working groups at big science and it's
really interesting because like
typically it's been like well we're
going to get the most data we can stuff
it in a language model and it's going to
be great it's going to learn all this
stuff but you know what's actually in
there there's so much
kind of
weird stuff on the internet especially
um and things that you don't necessarily
want your model to be uh to be seeing so
we're really looking into like mindful
data curation and and multilingual
multilingualism as well to make sure
that it's not just 100 english or 99
english so
it's such a like great initiative and
you know it makes me excited to be
involved that is so exciting i love the
trying to evaluate the carbon footprint
of a email or the admissions
yeah people did it like depending on the
attachment or not and blah blah but you
know it was just like because we found
this article of i think it was like a
theoretical physics project and they did
that they did like
everything video calls um travel commute
uh emails like the actual like uh
experiments as well and they made this
pie chart and it was really cool because
there was like i don't know 37
categories in the pie chart and we're
like we want to do that but i don't know
if we want to go into that level of
detail but we were going to ask um do a
survey and ask participants like you
know an average how many hours did you
spend uh working on big science or like
training in language models and things
like that so we didn't want like uh
a complimentary not just like
the number of gpu hours for training the
model but also like people's um
implication and participation in the
project that is so so interesting
could you um could you speak a little
bit more to the environmental impact of
ai
and what yeah it's um it's a topic i got
an alden a couple of years ago three
years ago now um the first article that
came out uh was by emma's trebel and her
colleagues and they essentially trained
a large language model um
with hyper parameter tuning so like
essentially looking at all the different
configurations and then the figure they
got was like that training uh that ai
model emitted as much carbon as five
cars in their lifetimes like including
gas including everything like the
average kind of consumption and
with my with my colleagues at neil we
were like well that doesn't sound right
like it can't be all models right and so
we really went off the deep end into
like figuring out what has an impact on
emissions how can we measure emissions
so first we just created this online
calculator where someone could enter uh
what hardware they used uh how long they
trained for
and where like on what essentially
either a location or a cloud computing
instance and it would give them an
estimate of the carbon involved that
they emitted essentially that was like
our first attempt it's like a calculator
and then um
we helped create a package called
codecarbon which actually does that in
real time so it's gonna like run in
parallel to whatever you're doing
training a model and then at the end
spit out an estimate of the carbon
emissions and
um lately we've been going kind of
further and further i just had an
article that i was a co-author on that
got accepted um that's about like how to
proactively reduce emissions so is there
like for example uh by anticipating uh
you know times when servers are not as
used as other times so like you know
kind of doing either time delaying or um
for example picking the right region
because if you train for example in um i
don't know
australia it's going to be a coal-based
grid and so it's going to be highly
polluting whereas in quebec in montreal
where i'm based it's 100
hydroelectricity so just by making that
choice you can reduce your emissions by
like a hundred fold right and so just
like small things like that like above
and beyond estimating we also want
people to start kind of reducing their
emissions it's like the next step that
is so fascinating i that i never crossed
my mind of where you're doing the actual
computing
oh yeah of course energy grids are like
this oh i got so i'm so into energy
grids now and like every time i go to
somewhere i'm like so what's the energy
coming from like how are you generating
it like is and so it's really
interesting like it's a there's a lot of
historical factors there's a lot of
cultural factors you know like france is
going to be nuclear uh mostly energy you
know canada has a lot of hydroelectric
energy um some people some places have
like a lot of wind or tidal um and so
it's really interesting just to kind of
understand you know when you turn on
like if you
uh turn on the lamp where that
electricity is coming from and like at
what cost to the environment essentially
because you know when i was growing up i
was always like turn off the lights you
know unplug whatever
but
not anything more than that it was just
like good best practices right like you
turn off the light when you're not in a
room but
after that you can really go deeper into
like
depending on where you live your
energy's coming from different sources
and they're more or less polluting and
blah blah blah like we just don't see
that right we don't see how energy is
produced we just see the light and we're
like oh this is my lamp right so so it's
really important to kind of start
thinking about that so easy not to think
about that
no i couldn't mean a major barrier for
even machine learning engineers
that might not have that general
awareness
yeah exactly and i mean usually it's
just by habit right you i think there's
like a default option when you when
you're using cloud instances often it's
like well the closest one to you or the
one with the most uh gpus available or
whatever like there's a defaulting and
people are like okay fine whatever right
like click the default it's like this
nudge theory aspect um
i i did a a master's in cognitive
science and we studied like just by
changing the default option
you can change people's behavior to an
incredible degree um you know like small
stuff like uh whether you put apples or
chocolate bars near the cash register or
like like small stuff like that and so
if the default option all of a sudden
was like the low carbon one
we could save so much so many emissions
just because people are just like oh
yeah okay fine i'm gonna train a model
in montreal like i don't care right like
it doesn't really matter as long as you
have access to the hardware you need you
don't really care where it is
but in in the in the long run it really
adds up
wow
what what are some of the ways that
machine learning teams and engineers
could
be a bit more proactive in aspects like
that
so i think that
i've noticed a little bit that there's a
certain disconnect between like a lot of
people are really environmentally
conscious like you know they'll i don't
know bike to work or they'll you know
eat
less meat and things like that like
they'll have this kind of environmental
awareness but then disassociate it from
their like their work because we're not
really aware of our impact as as machine
learning researchers or engineers on the
environment and so you know starting to
measure just like just
without sharing it necessarily just
starting to measure for example carbon
emissions starting to look um at what
instances you're picking if you have a
choice to try to see because like for
example i know that uh google cloud and
aws has started putting like low carbon
as a little like tag
uh so you can pick it like it's there
the information is there right and
starting to make these little steps and
i think that you know connecting the
dots between environment and and tech
essentially that's like a yeah that's a
dot that these are dots that are not
often connected because tech is so like
cloud it's like it's distributed right
you don't really see it and so
uh
but by connecting it by grounding it
more
you see like the impact it can have on
the environment
yeah that's a really good point
and you i've listened to a couple talks
and podcasts of yours and you've also
talked about how
machine learning can then be used to
yeah we wrote a paper a couple of years
ago that was
really a really really cool experience
so it's like almost 100 pages it's
called tackling climate change with
machine learning and we're like 25
authors but um there's all these
different sections like ranging from
electricity to uh city planning to uh i
don't know transportation to um forestry
and agriculture like we essentially have
these chapters of the paper where we
talk about the kind of the problems that
exist uh for example um
for example renewable energy uh it's
variable in in a lot of cases so for
example if you have solar panels they
will produce energy at night right
that's kind of like a given uh and then
so for example wind power is dependent
on the wind and so uh typically a big
challenge in implementing renewable
energy is that
you have to have like you have to
respond to the demand right you need to
be able to give people power at night
even if like even if you're on solar
energy so typically you have like either
diesel generators or you have like this
backup system that often like cancels
out the environmental effect um like the
the emissions that you're saving but
what machine learning can do you can do
predictive um like essentially you're
predicting how much energy will be
needed so based on like previous days
based on the temperature based on
i don't know even like events that
happen you can start being like okay
well we're gonna be predicting half an
hour out or an hour out or six hours or
24 hours and you can start having
different horizons and doing time for
time series prediction
and then instead of powering up a diesel
generator the diesel generators are cool
because you can just like power them up
and then like in you know a couple of
seconds they're up and running um what
you can also do is have batteries and
then you but but batteries you need to
start charging them ahead of time so say
you're six hours out you start charging
your batteries knowing that either
there's a cloud coming or that night's
gonna fall so you need that energy
stored ahead right and so there's things
that you could do that are really like
proactive that can make a huge
difference and then machine learning is
really good at that we're good at
predicting the future is good at you
know finding the right features and
things like that so that's like one of
the go-to examples um
another one is like uh remote sensing so
we have a lot of satellite data about
the planet and seeing either
deforestation or also like tracking
wildfires in a lot of cases you can you
can like detect wildfires automatically
based on satellite imagery um and like
deploy people right away because like
they're often in remote places that you
don't necessarily have people living in
and so like there's all these different
cases in which machine learning can be
like super useful we have the data we
have like the need and so this paper is
all about like how to get involved and
how to essentially whatever whatever
you're good at whatever you like doing
using machine learning how to apply that
and use it in the fight against climate
change
wow
that is so fascinating
uh
one thing that maybe this is a silly
question but
um
so for
people listening that are interested in
this effort but perhaps work at an
organization where it's not prioritized
i'm just thinking again like that
disconnect is so easy to have with the
environmental impact of ai
are there like any
tips or tricks you've picked up along
the way of
incentivizing
teams or engineers to
prioritize so i think that it's also
it's always a question of kind of cost
and benefit or time you know the time
that you need to put in and um
and sometimes people just don't know
that there are different
either either tools that exist or like
approaches and so
if people are really kind of interested
or even curious uh learning about it and
i think that's really the first step
because even me when when i first
started thinking of like what can i do
i didn't know i didn't know that all
these things existed people have been
working on this for like a fairly long
time uh in like using different data
science techniques and finding it so
just like starting to read about it like
for example uh we created a website
climatechange.ai
and we have like interactive summaries
that you can read and they're like
literally like three sentences about you
know how
climate change can help and detect
methane or whatever right and you can
read about it and i think that just by
like sprinkling this knowledge can help
already like
trigger some interesting thought
processes or discussions like i've i've
participated in several like round
tables at companies who are not
traditionally like you know climate
change oriented but who are starting to
think about it and they're like okay we
started you know i don't know we bought
a we put a composting bin in the kitchen
and we did this and we did that so and
then from the tech side what can we do
right and then it's really interesting
because it's like
there's a lot of low um hanging fruit
that you just need to learn about and
then
it's like oh i can do that i can i can
you know by default
use this cloud computing instance and
that's not going to cost me anything and
it's just like
it's just you need to change a parameter
somewhere
[Music]
essentially
yeah
yeah i feel like those are key
um
what are some of the more common
mistakes you see
machine learning engineers or teams make
when it comes to implementation
of some of these improvements or just
environments something that i've seen a
lot i mean actually apparently machine
learning people have or like ai people
in general have this
stereotype
like from other communities that we just
like
we think ai's gonna solve everything we
just arrived and we're like oh we're
gonna do ai and it's gonna solve all
your problems no matter what you guys
have been doing for 50 years like ai's
gonna do it
and i haven't seen that really i haven't
seen that um attitude that much but it's
true that we we tend to have our
because like we know what ai can do we
know what machine learning can do and we
have a certain kind of it's like a
world view and so like when we see it's
like when you when you have a hammer
everything's a nail so it's kind of
something like that like i've
participated in a couple of like
hackathons and and and kind of just like
general like people want to make stuff
or or do stuff to fight climate change
and it's often like oh this sounds like
a great thing ai can do we're gonna do
it without thinking of like how it's
gonna be used or how it's gonna be
useful or how it's gonna be right like
because it's like yeah sure ai can do
all this stuff but then at the end of
the day
someone's gonna use it or it's to have
to like for example you know if you
create some
some for example uh
something for for scanning
satellite imagery and detecting
wildfires for example the example i gave
well the information that your model
outputs has to be interpretable or you
know for example you need to add that
little extra step of like sending an
email or like or whatever it is right
because otherwise it's like
we train a model it's great it's super
accurate blah blah blah but then at the
end of the day nobody's going to use it
just because it's missing like a tiny
tiny little connection to the real world
or to like you know the way that people
will use this and so that's often been
and that's like that's like not sexy
people are like yeah whatever like i
don't i don't even know how to write a
script that sends an email i don't
either right but but still just like
doing that little extra step that's like
so so much less technologically complex
than what you've done so far just like
adding that little thing will will make
a big difference and it can be in terms
of ui it can be in terms of like
creating an app it can be in terms of
it's like the non-machine learning stuff
that's actually really crucial for your
project to be um
to be used and you know um i've
participated in organizing workshops
where people like submit ideas that like
are super great on paper that have great
like accuracy rates but then they just
kind of stagnate in in paper form which
is or
article form because
you still need to have that next step of
like like i remember this one
presentation of
um a machine learning algorithm that
could reduce um flight emissions like by
airplanes by something like three to
seven percent by calculating the wind
speed and the blah blah blah
and then
like of course that person should have
done a startup like or you know a
product or pitch this to boeing or
whatever but like but otherwise it was
just paper that they published in this
workshop that i was organizing and then
that was it
and
and of course scientists or engineers
don't necessarily have those skills
necessary to like you know go see a
airplane manufacturer with this thing
but it's it's really frustrating at the
end of the day to see this these great
ideas this great tech that just kind of
sizzles fizzles
so sad
oh my goodness that's such a great story
though and how you know there's
opportunities like that you know well
yeah and it can also be like i think
scientists often don't necessarily want
to make money they just want to like
solve problems often and so like you
don't necessarily even need to start a
startup you could just like talk to
someone or pitch this to someone but you
know you have to get out of your comfort
zone and the conference is the academic
conferences you go to you need to like
go to a networking event in the aviation
industry and that's scary right
and so um and so yeah there's often
these barriers between disciplines that
i find very very sad i actually really
like going to like
business or or yeah like random industry
work networking events because
this is where connections can get made
that can make the biggest changes it's
not in like the industry specific
conferences because everyone's talking
about the same technical stuff
that of course yeah they're making
progress and making innovations but then
if you go to these like if you're like
the only machine learning expert in a
room full of aviation experts you can do
so much you can really like spark all
these little sparks um and after that
you're gonna have people like you know
reducing emissions of fights
interested to hear more about
this
thought process that you have behind
what motivates you personally in your
work in ai machine learning and that
revolves around meaning yeah there's
this uh concept that my my mom uh read
about in some magazine like ages ago
when i was a kid um it's called ikigai
and it's a japanese concept and it's
like how to find
the reason or the meaning of life it's
kind of like how to find your place in
the universe and it was like you need to
find something that has like these four
elements if it was like what you love
doing what you're good at um what the
world needs and then what can be a
career this is kind of like i was always
like here's my careers but she was like
no because like even if you really love
doing this but you know you can't get
paid for it then that's
hard life as well and so she always like
asked me this when i was like picking my
courses at university or even like my
degree she'll always be like okay well
is that aligned with like things you
love and things you're good at and like
something she would like she'd be like
yeah but okay you're not really good at
that
i mean you could really want to do this
but maybe this is not what you're good
at um
and so i think that
it's always been kind of my driving
factor um in my career and
you know
i feel that it really helps
feel that you're you're useful and
you're uh
you're like a positive force in the
world and so for example when i was
working at morgan stanley i felt that
you know really interesting problems
like i was i was doing really well no no
questions asked like
the salary was amazing
um no complaints there but there was
missing this like what the world needs
aspect that um was like kind of like
this kind of like an itch i couldn't
scratch essentially and um and so like
but given given this this framing this
icky guy i was like oh that that's
what's missing in my life and
and so
i think that
i mean people in general not only in
machine learning it's good to to think
about like not only what you're good at
but also what you love doing and what
motivates you and like why you would get
out of bed in the morning and of course
having this aspect of what the world
needs and it doesn't have to be like you
know solving world hunger it can be like
on a much smaller scale or on a much
more conceptual scale like for example
what i feel that what we're doing at
hugging face is really like the world
needs okay machine learning needs more
um open source code more model sharing
but like not because it's going to solve
any one particular problem because it
can contribute to a large
like a a spectrum of problems anything
from like reproducibility
to like compatibility to products to
right like but there's like this this
the world needs this uh to some extent
and then so i think that really helped
me um converge on hugging face as being
like maybe the
the world doesn't necessarily need like
better social networks or you know
because a lot of people doing ai
research in the context of social media
or
um you know these big tech companies but
maybe the world doesn't necessarily need
that maybe not right now maybe what the
world needs is something different right
and so this this kind of four
four part uh framing
really helped me find meaning in my in
my
i guess my career and you know my my
life in general uh trying to find all
these poor elements
i love that and i'm curious what other
examples or applications do you find and
see potential meaning in
in ai machine learning i think that um
an often overlooked aspect is like
excessive accessibility and i guess
democratization but like
making ai
easier for non-specialists because like
can you imagine if
i don't know anyone like a journalist or
a doctor or or anyone right like any
profession you can think of could like
easily um train or use an ai model but
like from their point of view because i
feel like yeah for sure we do ai in in
medicine and healthcare right but it's
from a very
ai machine learning angle but if we had
more like
doctors who were empowered to create
more tools or
uh but like but like any profession uh
like a baker like i actually have a
friend who has a bakery here in montreal
and he was like yeah well can ai help me
like make a better bread and i was like
probably yeah like i'm sure that if you
did some kind of like experimentation
and like he's like oh i can install a
camera in my uh in my like oven and i'm
like oh yeah you could do that i guess i
mean like we were talking about it and
you know actually bread is pretty fickle
you need like the right humidity and the
right and it actually takes a lot of
experimentation and a lot of like
know-how from
longer in french and so like oh say same
thing for croissants his croissants are
so good and he's like yeah well you need
to really know the right butter the
right blah blah blah anyway and he was
like i want to do like an ai model that
will help me do make big bread and i was
like i don't even know how to help you
start like
like where do you start doing that right
um and so
like accessibility is such an important
part and like for example the internet
has become so accessible nowadays right
like anyone can navigate initially it
was it was a lot less so so
i think that ai still has some some
some
some road to travel in order to become a
more accessible and democratic tool
yeah absolutely and you've talked before
too about
like the power of data and how it's not
talked about enough and i think of what
you just mentioned like with the bread
stuff or the medical field or
you know the coral reefs that we were
trying about before the
amount of accessible data or just even
talking about
how to attain that
yeah
once um like
four or five years ago we went to costa
rica with my with my husband on a trip
and we ended up like we were just
looking at a map and then i found this
like research center that was like at
the edge of the world it was like
something in the middle of nowhere we
had to take like a car on a dirt road
then a first boat then a second boat to
get there um and they're in the middle
of the jungle and they essentially study
the jungle
and they have all these like camera
traps that are essentially like um
automatically
uh activated cameras that are like all
over the jungle and then like every
couple of days they have to hike from
camera to camera to switch out the sd
cards and then they take these sd cards
back to the uh to the to the station and
then they have a laptop and they have to
go through every picture it took and of
course there's a lot of false positives
because of like wind or whatever like a
really animal moving fast and they have
like like there's literally maybe like
five percent of actual good images
um and then and i was like why aren't
they using ai
to track biodiversity and then there's
like no like oh we saw a jaguar on blah
blah blah at this um like station i mean
at this like location because they have
a bunch of them and then they would try
to track of like you know if if a jaguar
or another animal got killed if it had
babies if it looked injured like all of
these different things and then i was
like
i'm sure a part of that could be
automated at least like the filtering
process of like taking out the images
that are essentially not useful but they
had graduate students or whatever doing
it but but still like you know there's
so many examples like this like in all
domains in all areas um and just having
these little tools i'm not saying like
because i think we're not there yet i'm
completely replacing scientists in this
kind of um this kind of task but just
like small components that are really
annoying
and like really time consuming then
machine learning can really help bridge
that gap
yeah absolutely oh that's so interesting
that they're it's actually really
chromatic data is a really huge part of
tracking biodiversity and it's used in
like for birds it's used for animals
it's used in a lot of cases and actually
now it's picking up there's a kaggle
competitions um the last couple years um
around camera trap data and essentially
like during the year they have camera
traps in different like especially like
kenya has a bunch and like tanzania as
well and then at the end of the at the
end of the year they have this big
kaggle competition of um
essentially uh recognizing different
species of animals and and then after
that they deploy the models um and like
and then they update them every year
essentially so it is it's starting it's
picking up but there's just a lot of
data as you said there's so much so much
and then essentially each each ecosystem
is unique and so you need a model that's
going to be trained on exactly like you
can't take a model from kenya and make
it work in costa rica it's not going to
work so you need data you need like
experts to train the model so there's a
lot of there's a lot of elements that
need to converge in order for for you to
be able to do this so far but can you
imagine if there was really like
like kind of like auto train hugging
face has auto train but you know even
even simpler where like uh a
biodiversity researcher in costa rica
could be like these are my images like
help me figure out which ones are good
quality and like the types of animals
that are on them and they could just
like drag and drop the images and like a
you know a web ui or something and then
they had this model that's like here are
the 12 images of jaguars this one is you
know injured this one has a baby blah
blah
exactly
oh my gosh that's
not so cool
um
the other thing that you know that has
to do with data is there might be
curious to if you have insights around
teams that are trying to accomplish
things with machine learning but just
lack the necessary data
and you know are there sources or tips
or information that you have
in regards to yeah i think
uh i guess another anecdote a lot of
these headings at some point we wanted
to organize um an ai for social good
hackathon here in montreal like three or
three or four years ago and then we were
like we're going to contact all these
ngos like soup kitchens homeless
shelters in montreal we're gonna like do
good and we started going to these
places and then we're like okay where's
your data and they're like uh
what data i'm like well you know don't
you keep track of like
how many people you have in your
homeless shelter or like if they come
back and they're like no and then and
then they're like but on the other hand
you know we have these problems of
either um you know people disappearing
and we don't know where they are or or
um people staying for a long time and
then at certain point we're supposed to
like not let them stay like they had a
lot of issues or like for example a food
kitchen and they had a lot of wasted
food because um you know they they had
trouble predicting how many people would
arrive and and sometimes like yeah we
noticed that you know in october usually
there's less people but we don't really
have any data to support that anyway so
we completely canceled the hackathon and
then instead we did um
i think we called them data literacy or
digital literacy workshops so
essentially we went to these places i
mean if they were interested and we gave
kind of like one or two hour workshops
about you know how to use a spreadsheet
and like figure out what they wanted to
try because sometimes they they didn't
even know what kind of things they
wanted to to
to save or they wanted to to really have
a trace of and so we did these uh i
think like we did a couple of them in
some places like we'd come back every
couple of months and like check in and
then a year later we had a couple like
especially a food kitchen um they
actually like we
managed to make a connection between
them and like um
i don't know what the company name was
anymore but they essentially did like
this uh supply chain management software
thing and so the soup kitchen was
actually able to like implement a system
where they would track like we got 100
or like whatever 10 pounds of tomatoes
and blah blah blah blah this many people
showed up today and this is the waste
food we have and a year later we were
able to do a hackathon to help them
reduce food uh food waste sorry uh and
that was really cool because we really
saw like a year and some before they had
no trace of anything they just had
intuitions which were useful but weren't
like formal and then like a year later
we were able to actually get data and
then like integrate it into their app
and then they would have a thing saying
oh be careful your tomatoes are going to
go bad soon because it's been three days
since you had them or and then in cases
where it's like pasta it would be like
whatever like six months or a year and
so that we we implemented the system
that would actually like give alerts to
them when it was like super simple in
terms of technology there was not even
much ai in there but just something that
would like help them keep track of
different categories of food and so
it was a really interesting experience
because i realized that you know yeah
you can come in and be like we're gonna
help you do whatever um but if you don't
have any data like what are you gonna do
yeah
exactly
oh that's so
interesting that's so amazing though
that you were able to jump in there and
just even provide like that first step
the educational piece of that puzzle
to get them set up on something like
that yeah i really i really like i mean
it's been a while since i organized any
hackathons but i think these like
community
involvement events are really important
because
they help people learn stuff like we
learned that you can't just like barge
in and use ai that you really need to
like digital literacy is so much more
important and sometimes they don't even
have like they just
never really put the effort into into
collecting the data even if they needed
it or they didn't know what could be
done and things like that so you know
taking this effort or five steps back
and and helping um you know improve tech
skills generally speaking is a really
useful contribution that people don't
really realize is is an option i guess
yeah
very cool
what industries are you most excited to
see machine learning be applied climate
change
yeah environment is like kind of my my
number one um education's always been
something that i've like really been
interested in and i've kind of been
always been waiting like i did my phd in
in education and ai like how ai can be
used in education i keep on waiting for
it to like finally
hit a certain peak but it's kind of i
guess there's a lot of
um
contextual elements and stuff like that
but like i think ai and education
machine learning and education can be
used in so many different ways from like
um you know helping people for example
what i was working on during my phd was
like how to help pick um activities like
learning activities and exercises that
are
best suited for learners um you know
instead of like giving all kids or
adults or whatever the same exercise to
help them like focus on their um
like weak
like weak knowledge points and weak
skills and focusing on those so instead
of like a one-size-fits-all approach and
like not and really like not replacing
the teacher but like like tutoring more
like the actual like okay you learn a
concept in school for example and help
you work on it and you know if someone
figured this one out really fast they
don't need those exercises but someone
else could need more time to practice
and i think that
there's so much that can be done but
i still don't see it really being used
but i think it's potentially really
impactful
very cool
all right so we're going to dive into
rapid fire questions and even though
they're rapid fire if you want to expand
on any feel free
uh but i think these are this is a super
fun part just to get
a
kind of larger perspective of yours in
terms of machine learning
some other weird questions but
so if you could go back and do one thing
differently at the start of your machine
learning career what would it be i would
spend more time um focusing on math so
as i said my two parents
are mathematicians and they would like
always give me like extra math exercises
and they would always be like math is
universal math math and so you know when
you do when you get force-fed things in
your childhood you don't necessarily
appreciate them later and so i was like
no languages and so i kind of really
like for a couple of i mean for a good
part
of my university studies i was like no
math no no only like humanities and so i
feel like if i had been a bit more open
from the beginning and kind of realized
the potential of math even in
linguistics even in like a lot of things
i think i would have you know come to to
where i'm at much faster than spending
like three years being like no no math
no no no
i remember like in grade in grade 12 in
my final year of high school like my
parents made me sign up for a math
competition like an olympiad and then i
want it and then i remember i had a
medal and i put it on my mom and i'm
like now leave me alone
i'm not gonna do any more math in my
life and she was like yeah yeah and then
after that when i was picking my phd
program she's like oh i see there's math
classes eh because you're doing machine
learning eh i was like
no
but yeah i i should have gotten over my
my initial distaste for math a lot
quicker that's so funny that's
interesting to hear that because i often
too will hear people say oh you need to
know less and less math
you know the more advanced some of these
libraries and programs definitely but i
think having a good base i'm not saying
you have to be like super genius but
having like this intuition like when
when i was working with joshua for
example he's like a total mass genius
and like just the facility
of like interpreting results or
understanding behaviors of a machine
learning model just because the math is
so like second nature whereas for me i
have to be like okay so i'm going to
write this equation with a loss function
i'm going to try to understand what the
what the consequence is blah blah blah
right it's just like you know it's it's
a bit less automatic but it's like it's
a skill that you can develop it's not
necessarily based on theoretical it
could be also like experimental
knowledge
um but just having like this really
solid math background helps you like get
there quicker i think you can really
kind of like skip a few steps
that was brilliant and you got
the best oh my god no i know i refuse to
ask my parents for help no way
plus since they're like theoretical
mathematicians they think machine
learning is just like for people who
aren't good at math and who are lazy or
whatever
and so it's like you know there's like
all this um you know depending on
whatever area you're in there's like
there's pure mathematicians like
theoretical mathematicians there's
applied mathematicians there's like
statisticians there's like there's all
these different camps and so
i remember like my little brother also
like was like thinking of going to
machine learning and my dad was like
no stay in theoretical math that's where
all like the geniuses i don't know i
remember how he put it he was like no
like math machine learning is where like
math goes to die
it's like dad i'm here he was like well
you know i'd rather your brother stayed
in just in something more refined
that's not fair
so yeah yeah there's definitely this
like well because like there is a lot of
empirical like aspects in machine
learning there's a lot of trial and
error like you're tuning hyper
parameters and you don't really know why
and so i think formal mathematicians
unless there's like a formula they they
don't think it's it's real they don't
think it's legit
that is so
funny
so besides maybe a mathematical
foundation what advice would you give to
someone looking to get into machine
learning i think um getting your hands
dirty and and like starting out with uh
jupiter notebooks or or
coding exercises things like that so so
especially you know if you do have
specific
angles or problems you want to get into
uh or or just ideas in general like
starting to try like i remember
the first like i did a summer school
machine learning when i was like in the
beginning of my phd i think and then it
was really interesting but then it was
like all these examples like they're
such like they were so disconnected from
like i don't remember what like what the
data was like cats versus dogs i don't
know it was like yeah but like why am i
gonna use that like and then they're
like
part of the exercise was like find
something that you want to use like a
classifier essentially to do
and then uh i remember i got like
pictures of flowers or something and i
got super into it i was like yeah see it
like confuses this flower and that
flower because they're kind of similar i
understand i need more images like i got
super into it and that's when it clicked
in my head like it's not only this like
super abstract classification or like oh
yeah i remember we were using this
datashot called mnist
which is super uh
popular because it's like uh handwritten
digits and they're really small and it's
like the network goes fast so people use
it a lot in beginning uh in the
beginning of like machine learning
courses i was like who cares like i
don't wanna classify ditches like
whatever right and then when they let us
pick our own images all of a sudden it
gets a lot more personal and interesting
and captivating so so i think that if
people are like kind of stuck in a rut
they can really focus on things that
that interests them and even like you
know for example related to climate
change get some climate change data and
start playing around with it and you
know it really makes the process more
pleasant
i love that find something that you're
interested in and almost like exactly
yeah and like one of the my favorite
projects i've worked on um was
classifying butterflies we trained
neural networks to classify butterflies
based on like pictures people took
and it was like so much fun it was just
like it's like you learn so much and
then you're also like solving a problem
that you understand why like how it's
gonna be used and so i was like it was
such a great thing to be involved in and
like i wish that
you know everyone have found this like
kind of
interest in the work they do because you
you really feel that it's it's like
yeah you're making a difference and it's
cool and it's fun and it's interesting
and you wanna and you wanna do more and
like for example um
i mean just tangent but this project was
done in partnership with um the montreal
insectarium which is like a museum for
insects and um i kept in touch with a
lot of these people and then they just
renovated the insectarium and they're
opening it after like three years of
renovation this weekend and they like
invited me and my family to the opening
and i'm like so excited to go there
until like you can actually like handle
insects they gonna have stick bugs
they're gonna have a big greenhouse
where there's butterflies everywhere and
then that greenhouse um like i mean you
have to install the app but you can take
pictures of butterflies and then it uses
our ai network to identify them and i'm
like so excited to go there and to use
the app
and to see my kids using it and to like
see this whole thing because like before
like the old version they would give you
like this little um
pamphlet and with pictures of
butterflies and you have to go find them
and then i just can't wait to see the
difference between like that like static
representation and this like actual app
that you could use to take pictures of
butterflies
oh my gosh and how cool
to see something that you created
exactly and even if it's not like you
know fighting climate change but it's
like i think it could make a big
difference into like helping people
appreciate nature and biodiversity and
like taking things from something that's
like so abstract and like
two-dimensional and kind of like
whatever yeah pictures of butterflies to
like something that you can really like
get involved in and take pictures like i
think that that makes a huge difference
in terms of like our perception and our
um yeah like our connection right it
helps you make a connection between
yourself and nature for example
oh i think that's so beautiful i'm so
excited
oh that's very cool
uh
let's see oh should people be afraid of
ai taking over the world i think that uh
we're really far from it i i guess it
depends on what you mean by taking the
world but
i think that we should be a lot more
mindful of what's going on right now
instead of kind of thinking to the
future being like oh terminator whatever
to kind of be aware of how ai is being
used in you know our phones in our lives
and to be more cognizant of that and and
you know
technology and general events in general
we have more influence on them than we
think right by um
i don't know by using alexa
we are giving you know money or any kind
of tool not alex in particular but like
alexa or you know siri or whatever we're
giving like we're giving agency we're
giving not only like material uh you
know funds to the to this technology and
you know we can also
participate into it like for example you
know oh i'm gonna opt out of my data
being used for whatever if i i'm using
this technology right oh i'm going to
read the fine print and figure out like
you know what it is that's that that ai
is doing in this case right and and
being more involved in general so i
think that people are are really like
look seeing ai is like a very distant
kind of potential mega threat but it's
actually a current threat but on a
different scale so it's like a different
perception it's like you know instead of
thinking of like this like agi or
whatever start thinking about the small
things in our lives that ai is being
used for and then engage with them and
then it's going to make it more you know
there's going to be less chance that agi
is going to take over the world if you
know
you make the more mindful choices about
data sharing about consent about uh i
don't know using technology in certain
ways like you know if if you find out
that your your what for example your
police force in your city is using a
facial recognition technology you can
speak up about that that's part of your
rights as a citizen in many places right
and so it's like by by engaging yourself
you actually have um
you can have an influence on the future
by engaging in the present
i like that that makes me feel better
too uh
what are you interested in right now it
could be anything it could be a movie a
recipe a podcast
um so during the pandemic uh like the
lockdowns and stuff like that i got
super into plants i bought so many
plants and then now we're um preparing
uh a garden with my with my children so
we actually planted this the first time
i've done this we planted seeds for like
tomatoes and peppers and cucumbers i
usually just like buy them at the
groceries or wherever when they're
already like all ready but this time
around i was like no i want to teach my
kids but i also want to learn my myself
what the whole process is and so we
planted them like maybe 10 days ago and
they're starting to to grow
and like you know watering them every
day and
i think that like this is kind of also
like part of this this process of like
learning more about nature and the
conditions that like you can help plants
thrive and stuff like that so so we're
really like we're last summer already we
we built um like just a square
essentially that we filled in with dirt
but this year we're trying to make it
better i want to have like several
several levels and stuff like that so
i'm really looking forward to
to learning more about like growing your
own food
that is so cool i feel like that's such
a grounding yeah and it's so like it's
like it's like the polar opposite of
what i do like it's great to like
not do something on my computer but just
like go outside and have like dirty
fingernails and like and i remember like
being so like who would want to do
gardening it's so boring and now i'm
like super into gardening
i'm like i can't wait till the weekend
to go garden
yeah
oh that's great if there is something so
rewarding about creating something that
you can see touch feel smell
as opposed to pushing pixels yeah
exactly it's like a different like
sometimes you spend a whole day like
grappling with this program that has
bugs in it and it's not working you're
like so frustrating and then you go
outside and you're like but i have
cherry tomatoes
it's all
i'm good go deal with these other bugs
awesome
um
what are some of your favorite machine
learning papers um my favorite i think
currently like
papers um
by a researcher or by a baba berhan
who's um a researcher in like ai ethics
and she writes it's like a completely
different way of looking at things so
for example she wrote a paper that just
got accepted to fact which is like a
fairness and ethics conference in ai
which was about like values and how the
way we do machine learning research is
actually driven by like the things that
we value and the things that you know
for example if i value a network that
has high accuracy for example
performance um i might be less willing
to for example um
like focus on efficiency so for example
i'll train a model for a really really
long time just because i want it to be
really accurate um or like if i wanna um
have something new like this like
novelty uh value i'm gonna be i'm not
gonna like read the literature and see
what people have been doing for whatever
10 years i'm going to be like i'm going
to reinvent this and so she has this
really interesting i mean her co-authors
write this really interesting paper
about you know the connection between
values that are kind of like theoretical
like kind of metaphysical and the way
that they're instantiated and machine
learning and i found that was really
interesting because typically we don't
see it that way typically it's like oh
well we have to establish
state-of-the-art we have to i don't know
whatever establish accuracy and do this
and that and that and then like site
related work but just like kind of it's
just like this thing like it's like a
check box right you just have to do it
and then they think a lot more in depth
about like why we're doing this and then
what are some
alternative ways of doing things that
you know for example
doing a trade-off between efficiency and
accuracy like if you have a model that's
slightly less accurate but that's a lot
more efficient and trains faster um that
could be like a good like way of
democratizing ai because people need
less computational resources to train a
model right and so there's like all
these different connections that they
make that i find really cool
wow
we'll definitely be linking
uh to that paper as well so people can
check that out yeah very cool
anything else you'd like to share
um
maybe things you're working on or that
you would like people to know about yeah
something i'm working on um outside of
big science is um
on evaluation and how we evaluate models
we'll kind of link to what ebba talks
about in their in her paper but like
even from just a pure machine learning
perspective what are the different ways
that we can evaluate models and you know
compare them on on different
aspects i guess not only accuracy but
efficiency and like carbon emissions and
things like that so there's a there's a
project that's um kind of started uh for
a month or so now of of like how how to
evaluate it in a way that's not only
like performance driven but that well
that takes into account different
aspects essentially and i think that
this has been a really overlooked um
aspect of machine learning like people
typically just once again just check off
like oh you have to evaluate this and
that and that and then submit our paper
but there's also these interesting
trade-offs that we could be doing and
things that we could be measuring that
we're not and so
and looking for example
if you have a data set and you have like
an average accuracy
is the accuracy the same again in
different subsets of the data set like
are are there for example patterns that
you can pick up on that will help you
improve your model but also make it more
fair like i mean i guess the typical
example is like you know uh image
recognition does it do the same
in different um
well i mean like the famous
gender shades paper about like you know
uh the algorithm did better on white men
than african-american women but like you
could do that about anything not only
gender and race but you could do that
about like i don't know for example for
images like color or types of objects or
angles like you know is it good for
images from above or images from street
level like there's all these different
ways of analyzing accuracy or
performance that we haven't really
looked at because it's typically more
time consuming right and so we want to
make tools to help people delve deeper
into the results and understand their
models better
that's brilliant
very cool and where can people find you
online uh i'm on twitter
sasha underscore mtl and um
yeah that's about it i have a website i
don't update it enough but um
twitter anything is the best
perfect we can link to that too sasha
thank you so much for joining me today
this has been
so insightful and amazing i really
appreciate it thank you for listening to
this episode of machine learning experts
if you or someone you know is interested
in direct access to leading machine
learning experts like sasha who are
ready to help accelerate your machine
learning roadmap please visit hf dot co
support to learn more
and we'll see you next time thanks